hey what is up everybody it's axel here
for anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the
strongest types of abilities available
to jujutsu sorcerers and curses
that being domain expansion these are
the
special ultimate attacks which only
extremely talented and powerful
individuals can perform
and even in those cases they are so
draining that they
rarely rely on them and this is likely
why
even 150 chapters in we've only seen
seven domain expansion users obviously
there are more who can use it but the
point still holds
domain expansions are extremely rare and
extremely badass
if you enjoy this video and want to see
more jiu jitsu kaizen content
on this channel be sure to leave a like
and maybe consider leaving a comment
with who you'd like to see me talk about
next
it will only take a second but it's a
huge help for the channel and
hey if you haven't subscribed to anime
uproar make this the video where you
subscribe
and be sure to click that bell and
select all notifications
you can also follow anime upper on
twitter and instagram at
anime uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt
finally this video will contain jiu
jitsu kaizen manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned in jiu jitsu kaizen
some of the most powerful techniques
are actually barrier-based abilities
while all domain
expansions tend to fall into this
category
we kind of have to discuss the building
blocks before we get into the real meat
of domain expansions
the most simplified version of barrier
techniques or domains i guess
could be considered the curtain
technique yes
obviously this isn't a domain in itself
however curtains do allow the user to
seal off an area from the outside world
this is typically used by jujutsu
sorcerers to keep their battles against
curses secret from the rest of society
however it can also be used by curses to
trap their victims inside
despite curtains being one of the
simpler barrier techniques we've only
seen about 5 people use them so far with
those being gojo
ghetto ijichi mahito and juzo while i
obviously wouldn't say this is a domain
the idea of separating one area from the
outside
is still present here curtains can also
be manipulated in some ways being made
more like physical barriers almost
and similar to how nen functions in
hunter hunter
if jujutsu sorcerers or curses add
restrictions to their curtains
they can make them incredibly powerful
for example saying only gojo is
restricted would make it
almost impossible for him to get through
and probably anyone who
wasn't gojo wouldn't be able to get
through at all
curtin users can also stand outside of
the barrier to make it stronger
essentially protecting something else
while leaving themselves vulnerable
this will also drastically increase the
strength of their barriers
so those are the basics of setting up
barriers within the jujutsu kaizen world
let's ramp up to domain expansions
themselves these can kind of be like
filling a barrier with your own jujutsu
essence
there are several different variations
of domains however to this point we've
only seen
seven domain expansion users in the
series
and originally i was going to discuss
them in order of how powerful they are
but like
all of them are pretty insane in their
own right so that's kind of out of the
window and i'm just gonna have to feel
my way through and
explain them how i feel is best domain
expansions involve the use of
massive amounts of cursed energy to
create what is essentially a pocket
dimension within a barrier these can be
next to impossible to escape from the
inside however
with enough effort they can be
penetrated from the outside
as it's explained if the goal is to hold
enemies
inside then the outer walls don't need
to be as strong
only an insane person would enter into
another's domain
that said there are other ways to escape
domains but we'll get into that a little
bit later
so what exactly does a domain expansion
do well aside from isolating the target
and the user together it also amplifies
the user's abilities and allows all of
their attacks to land on their opponents
yes all of them no matter what this
makes them insanely powerful for just
about anyone
however they are particularly powerful
when used in tandem with abilities which
are difficult to hit
that's because many of the abilities
which are difficult to land tend to have
that trade-off of having a more powerful
effect
and a perfect example of this is mahito
his curse ability enables him to change
the shape of a victim's soul
and morph their bodies into these
horrific transfigured forms
however there's a little bit of a
prerequisite that actually goes into
doing this
in order for mahito to transform a soul
he has to actually touch the person
if the person has an especially powerful
soul that might take a few extra touches
like with nanami
while people like itadori who is more in
tune with his own soul because of the
whole thing he has going on with sukuna
are nearly immune
now the condition of actually touching a
target can be pretty difficult when
you're dealing with what are essentially
super people
which leads us back to the idea of
domain expansion
mahito's domain expansion is called
self-embodiment of perfection which
firstly is probably the most disgusting
domain ability that we've seen
so far something about all those fingers
everywhere just
gives me the heebie-jeebies beyond just
being creepy though
self-embodiment of perfection basically
throws away the requirement of touching
people to manipulate their souls and
bodies allowing him to do it
at will that said the only time that
we've really seen him try and use it was
anonymity and that was interrupted by
sukuna
who immediately put mahito in his place
and
speaking of sukuna we might as well get
into his domain expansion
malevolent shrine while we don't know
all that much about tsukuna's abilities
in general we've only really seen him
fight a few times and
always very briefly we have got to see
him using domain expansions twice
first was against the finger bearer in
episode 4
which was kind of done so quick that we
don't really know what happened
all we saw was that the finger bear was
sliced into many different parts
later in chapter 119 we see sukna using
malevolent shrine against maharaga and
we get a more in-depth explanation here
sukuna's domain expansion has a range of
meters which in comparison to the ones
we've seen so far
is enormous and that's because tsukuna
kind of has a self-imposed condition
on his domain expansion that condition
being that he doesn't actually have a
barrier around the domain
the trade-off here being that people can
escape there's an open route
but the range is drastically expanded
the manga uses the description that
creating a domain without a barrier is
akin to an artist making a masterpiece
not on a canvas but on the air which is
so goddamn cool but what does his domain
actually do
and for him it's actually pretty simple
it just creates a never-ending assault
of attacks on
everything within the range if the
object is inanimate he has a slash
called dismantle which is
just a slash there's not a whole lot
special about it but
in the case that the object has cursed
energy an attack called cleave is used
this will boost the strength of the cut
depending on the toughness
or amount of curse energy that's
required to actually kill them in one
slice
and when we look at the brutality and
savagery that sukuna is known for
well this barrage of indiscriminate
devastating slashes
kind of fits him perfectly and while
we're on the topic of sukuna we might as
well
also cover the incomplete domain that
the finger bearer had in episode 4.
while he wasn't able to create a full
domain it was able to generate an innate
domain which basically warped the
reality of the building that they found
him in that being said the innate domain
doesn't really seem to amplify abilities
or to always make sure his attacks
connect though back to true
completed domain expansions we can look
at jogo's coffin of the iron mountain
and if you're picking up a trend of all
of these having really badass names
you're not the only one jogo in general
is a curse which
thrives using heat fire and explosive
based attacks
we even saw him spawning a mini volcano
on a wall that blasted at gojo
as such it's pretty fitting that his
domain is within a massive volcano
within this volcano jogo can manipulate
the earth
launching spikes of rocks at his
opponents and just
generally gets a leveled up set of
abilities gojo even mentions how the
average sorcerer would have just burned
up upon entering
that said he was using this against gojo
so it's not like he really had the
chance to do very much
the domain only really remained active
for a short period of time before gojo
used his own domain
unlimited void to completely suppress
coffin of the iron mountain
speaking of unlimited void much like
tsukunas it's
fairly unique while just about every
other domain that we've seen
is strictly offensive in a very direct
way
you know barrage of slashes changing
your body yada yada gojo's instead is
more of an overwhelming attack on your
senses
while the domain itself doesn't seem to
be able to hurt you physically
it floods the target with so much
information and sensory overload that
they basically go into shock
jogo describes it first as not being
able to see or feel
anything and then realizes that that
wasn't the case
he could actually see and feel
everything
it was too much for him to process and
he found himself immobilized as a result
so while unlimited void is unable to
actually hurt enemies itself so far at
least
it does open them up to any attack that
gojo wants to launch at them and
hypothetically
if you wanted to watch a whole video
about gojo's abilities and attacks
there should be a card in the top corner
or at least at the end of the video
for our discussion on just that topic
shameless plug aside
let's cover the final domain expansion
that we've seen in the anime with megumi
fushiguro's chimera shadow garden
megami's typical abilities involve
summoning shikigami from shadows
which is why his domain expansion floods
the area with shadows
and allows him to summon a slew of
shikigami all at once
this gives him a massive power boost but
it's still a fairly incomplete and new
ability
and pushes him to his absolute limits
and exhausts him
i'm sure that the next attempt or two
will kind of even out the edges and
allow him to be an even stronger
sorcerer going forward
we do see one more in the anime however
we don't really see it being used as an
actual attack
rather we see it being used well as a
vacation destination
the cursed dagon's horizon of
captivating skanda which i
can assure you i have probably
pronounced incorrectly
more or less allows him to produce a
tropical beach
which i mean most times is just kind of
chill however in the event he actually
needs to use it
offensively it becomes what i personally
would consider
the worst one to deal with sure it would
be pretty crappy to deal with being
transfigured or being slashed away or
whatever but this is genuinely something
of nightmares and that might just be
because of my fear of open water but
who's to say dagon essentially turns the
ocean within his domain into a machine
gun that constantly fires shikigami
sharks
and piranhas and other deadly fish in an
endless supply at his enemies until
they're devoured sure the other ones
might kill you faster
but this one i think i would like to
avoid most of all
and finally the first manga exclusive
domain expansion which belongs to the
smallpox deity a fairly minor curse that
we see quickly in the shibuya incident
this seals enemies in coffins
underground and then drops gravestones
on them
after 3 seconds if they haven't escaped
they will be infected with smallpox and
die
this can be used repeatedly over and
over again
and if there's more than one person in
the domain it will prioritize whoever
seems to have the strongest cursed
energy
this one is also nightmare fuel but
there's something about it that just
seems kind of silly to me
like all the other death methods are
pretty instant
and direct but there's something about
boom
you have smallpox that just doesn't fit
in with the rest of them
now all of these domains have one thing
in common they are extremely exhausting
on the user
to this point in the series it is
extremely rare that anyone is able to
use more than one domain in a day
however it was stated that gojo is able
to do so
if a sorcerer is caught in a domain they
do have a few options it's not just
game over right away firstly they can
hope that someone breaks you out
from the outside like itadore did with
nanami but
even then someone's gotta take the brunt
of an attack in this case it was sukna
which stopped it you can also
force your domain to overtake the
opponents similar to how gojo did
against jogo
and finally if you happen to be a weaker
sorcerer than the curse you are fighting
you can make a hole on the outside of it
by making a small domain within their
domain
and essentially leaving a hole behind
you like a back door
something we saw gojo doing while in
jogo's domain
was called domain amplification
basically covering himself in an aura
that negates any ability it comes into
contact with such as that
giant chunk of rock that jogo threw at
him and the last option
are special abilities that certain
families have so for example
falling blossom emotion is a secret art
for the big three sorcerer families
which allows for a counter-attack at the
moment that the guaranteed attack lands
but that is just about everything we
know about domain expansion and barrier
techniques in general so far if i had to
choose a favorite it would probably be
between gojo and tsukunas
i know kinda basic picks but let's be
real they're pretty awesome
but what are your favorites in the
series so far and what kind of domain
expansion do you think
other characters might have i would love
to see toto
or itadoris in the future especially if
itadori had some kind of parallel or
contrast to sukunas
i think that would be really really cool
and finally if you had a domain
expansion
what would you want it to do let me know
in the comments down below
these are some of the coolest parts of
the series and i would love to hear your
ideas so get creative
if you guys enjoyed this jujutsu kaizen
video and want to see more
please leave a like and if you're new to
anime uproar remember to subscribe and
ring that bell
by selecting all notifications you can
guarantee you won't miss any future
videos
that being said if you did miss our
previous video on gojo's powers and
abilities the other day you should
definitely be sure to go check that one
out
and of course you can also follow the
anime uproar boys
at anime uproar on twitter or instagram
or you can follow myself
at excellionyt i also have a video on my
own channel axelbeatz where i give my
thoughts on the first season of jujutsu
kaizen as a whole
so if you'd like to see similar videos
here on anime uproar covering manga arcs
please let us know that as well i want
to give a big thank you to the patron
squad over on patreon who helped make
videos like this possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord twego himself alpha
sigma
and our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata pate heffa al-jatal dr kortmann
the toasted chi emperor otaku spidey
life tinnell
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert
and monkey d quilly and of course our
pro hero patrons the one and only
gilgamesh
the red haired raven angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami
and water joanne garcia ted no ted
fatboy games corey mcgowan metal mama
deadly saint and
soul rye slice and dice thank you all so
much
if you do enjoy the work on this channel
you can go over to patreon.com
anime uproar and support the channel for
as little as one dollar
a month if you do so you will get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and of course you'll also get access to
the anime uproar exclusive patreon
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested
thanks again and until next time stay
excellent
[Music]
foreign